Hello everyone,
let me introduce myself.
My name is Damien Scalia,
I am a professor
at the Université Libre de Bruxelles,
I specialize in international criminal law
and international crimes.
I would first like
to thank Amah and Lilianne,
who kindly invited me to participate
in your seminar.
Today we are going to make
a rather theoretical
and short presentation
of the issues at stake
in this matter
mainly concerning...
This is why I was called
or why I was invited here:
it is mainly concerning
the crimes of the French army
or the crimes France committed
in Algeria.
We notice that these crimes
are of two kinds.
First, war crimes
or war crimes against humanity,
we will see them, since
the designation is important,
committed before the decolonization,
before 1962.
And also crimes committed
after 1962,
since we are also
going to look today
at the French nuclear tests
committed in the Sahara
which started before 1962,
but ended after 1962.
I will come back to this
in a few moments.
The objective of
this little presentation
will be to give an overview
of the actions that have been carried out
in relation to these events.
Those are events that have marked
and still do, the relations
between France and Algeria.
They marked the domination
of France over Algeria
and the colonization
of Algeria by France.
These dramatic events,
which today still have
firstly medical repercussions,
human repercussions as well,
but also legal ones.
Therefore there are two types of events,
like I said, the criminal acts
and the nuclear tests,
which I don't qualify as a crime
for the moment.
We will come back to it
since it is one of the questions
that will be asked
for the opening at the end of the class.
As far as the crimes are concerned,
it is common knowledge
and I will not go back over it,
that during the events in Algeria,
like France says,
or during the Algerian War,
which was qualified
of armed conflict
by the French Courts,
in particular,
during this war,
acts of torture, murders
and summary executions
were committed
by the French army
in the 1950s
and up until the very early 1960s.
I will not go back over
the facts themselves,
you know them.
If ever...
It could be an exercise to do
for the seminars to come,
the discussion seminars.
In parallel to this, nuclear tests
were conducted
from 1960 onwards,
in particular the first nuclear test
which was carried out at Reggane
in the Sahara.
These tests continued
until 1966,
meaning they began
before Algerian independence,
but they continued
under an agreement
that was annexed
to the Evian agreements in 1962.
They continued afterward,
that is to say, with the agreement
of the newly decolonized Algeria.
This raises a question,
an we will see it,
about Algeria's responsibility,
even if this agreement,
which was kept secret for a long time,
implied that the Sahara,
was not completely decolonized,
or in other words,
that Algeria did not have
complete sovereignty
over it.
These nuclear tests,
mainly A-bomb tests,
there were 17 in total
and they were recognized
very late,
just as the crimes
of the Algerian army were recognized
very late in the French law.
I will come back to this in a few moments
because I will come back to a law,
the Morin Law of 2010,
which not only recognized them, but allows
the victims
of those nuclear tests,
just as the victims
of the nuclear tests
in French Polynesia,
allows- so that Morin Law
of 2010,
allows the victims
to obtain reparations, compensations.
We will see
in what framework.
Before proceeding to a more
in-depth analysis
of our subject, which will be divided
in three parts.
I will firstly talk about the crimes
themselves and what has been done,
particularly before the French Courts
since 1980s.
Then, I will address the question
of nuclear testing
to tell you where we stand today
and what has or has not been done,
before seeing what potential avenues
are possible.
Those will ultimately be an opening
to the next seminars
that I will follow in part
at a distance
and in particular, by virtue of the class
that we will have at the start of October,
where I will be answering
a series of question
following today's class.
Before beginning this reflexion
in three sections,
I think it is important
to define two things.
One, crimes against humanity
and two, war crimes.
Why? Because these crimes
are at the heart of our concerns
about France's behavior
in Algeria
and without a definition,
even if it is only a quick one,
we will not understand
the rest.
So two things:
war crimes
and crimes against
humanity came into being,
legally speaking,
not factually,
but legally speaking,
came into being mainly
for the crimes against humanity
and were developed mainly
for war crimes,
at the time of Nuremberg.
Nuremberg was
the post-war judgment.
It is the judgment
that allowed the trial
of about twenty
senior Nazi officials
for war crimes,
crimes against humanity and at the time,
crimes against peace,
which would later become
the crime of aggression.
War crimes were defined
at that time
and will be up until 2002
with the establishment of the statute
of the International Criminal Court.
This Court now
prosecutes individuals
who have allegedly
committed war crimes,
crimes against humanity,
genocides or crimes of aggression.
War crimes are defined
as acts that take place
during an armed conflict.
Therefore, it is a fundamental
element of context,
during an armed conflict,
against protected persons
or protected property.
Who are these protected
persons or property?
They are military
who are no longer fighting
because they are wounded,
because they are prisoners of war.
They are the civilians who
cannot be military targets.
They are people who are
specially protected:
medical workers,
health workers, among others.
This is a very short definition.
We should...
We could go much further
in this definition,
but let's retain this,
it will be sufficient for our work.
Crimes against humanity,
which are very important,
even more important
than the others, are defined
in the Nuremberg status
in Article 6, as acts committed
against the civilian population
and consequently
against the civilian population.
At the time of Nuremberg,
they were defined
according to the context.
They could only occur in the context
of an armed conflict.
Today, these crimes are
possible outside of armed conflict.
Therefore, massive violations
of human rights
committed against the civilian population.
The text says: in the context
of a widespread
or systematic attack directed
against the civilian population.
So here we have something important,
namely a definition
that appeared in 1945 in the statute
of the Nuremberg Tribunal
and that will be developed,
just like the definition
of crimes against...
war crimes that will be
developed until 2002
and to this day.
Once those two definitions have been
established, we will see that
several legal or judicial
procedures have been opened,
and also closed, concerning the events
that interest us,
without actually succeeding.
For war crimes and crimes against humanity
in the stricter sense,
they have never been successful.
For the war crimes
of the French army in Algeria.
As for the nuclear tests,
they were not successful,
but they were not
judicial as a matter of course.
Note that we will be
talking here
about companies,
about procedures,
that have mainly targeted
individuals
or the French State,
but always within national procedures.
meaning that procedures
of the International Court of Justice type,
procedures of the UN International
Human Rights
Committee type
have not, to my knowledge,
been initiated
or have not been successful
in any case,
and I am putting aside
diplomatic procedures
which do not concern our class.
I do not address either,
at least not immediately,
the question of the procedures opened
or potentially opened in Algeria.
This will be the matter
of your research, I think,
since I do not know
Algerian law well enough.
I don't know Algerian
procedures too well,
so we can talk about that later.
So if you don't mind,
let's start
with the events outside of
the nuclear tests,
the events,
the crimes committed
by the French army in Algeria.
It is important to know that these events
were never recognized
as crimes against humanity,
nor, moreover, as war crimes,
and therefore
they benefited from
a French amnesty law
before the French Courts.
A little historical reminder:
in 1900, I mean, in the 1960s,
in 1966 and 1968 to be exact...
I mean, I'm sorry, in 1964,
France passed an amnesty law
that amnestied
all offenses committed
in the context of French interventions,
particularly in Algeria.
This law aims...
Well, it is a general
and absolute amnesty law.
It extends to all offenses,
which means
that it extends, at least
in French law implicitly,
to crimes that could be
qualified as war crimes
or crimes against humanity.
As early as the 1980s,
two procedures,
notably in 1986-88,
were initiated in France
for crimes committed:
murders and torture by the French army
against Algerian nationals.
These proceedings and without going into
the whole procedure,
led to two very important rulings
on November 29, 1988,
very important ones,
in particular the Ayyoub ruling,
rulings by the Criminal Division
of the Court of Cassation,
which very clearly
stated that
first, the crimes themselves
were not
crimes against humanity,
and second, that they were
therefore potentially
crimes under ordinary law,
but that these
were covered by an amnesty,
which was the amnesty
provided by the 1964 law.
This is very surprising,
as Pierrette Poncela
and Isabelle Fouchard
pointed out.
It is very surprising
because the Court of Cassation
had a completely different approach
in the Barbie case,
which concerned crimes
committed by Klaus Barbie
during the Second World War.
The Court of Cassation said
that the amnesty law
did not apply
to the crimes committed
by Klaus Barbie,
since this amnesty law
was mainly based
on the Nuremberg laws,
and that the crimes of the Nazis
or those associated with them
were not covered
by the amnesty law.
That is to say, with regard to the crimes
of the Second World War,
the judges of the French High Court
set aside the amnesty law
and, in a way,
made the law retroactive
in order to be able
to judge Klaus Barbie.
I will come back
to this retrogression
because it is quite
complicated,
but for the crimes in Algeria,
the Court of Cassation dismissed it.
Since 1988, the Court of Cassation
has never ruled differently.
It has dealt with judgments
concerning crimes
committed in Indochina,
in another former French colony,
the Boudarel judgment.
It has dealt with other cases,
notably in 2000,
for crimes committed in Algeria,
in a case of May 30, 2000,
and it has always gone
this direction.
Namely that,
on the one hand, the provisions
of the law of 1964,
which relate to the imprescriptibility
of crimes against humanity,
do not apply to crimes committed
in Algeria or elsewhere,
with the exception of crimes
committed by the Nazis
or in connection
with World War II.
There is therefore imprescriptibility,
which means that crimes
committed by the Nazis or in connection
with the Second World War
can be prosecuted ad vitam,
but not other crimes.
Moreover, and it clearly states this
in the 2000 judgment,
furthermore,
it considers that
the principles of legality
and non-retroactivity
are opposed to the application
of the new 1994 Penal Code
before its entry into force.
It should be noted that this new Penal Code
specifically incriminated
crimes against humanity
in French law,
meaning that before 1994,
there was no
incrimination of crimes against humanity
in French law.
This is why this Court
will consider
that Algerian crimes
are common law crimes,
and therefore that they can be
amnestied by the law of the 1960s.
Moreover, it will consider
in these same judgments
that international law,
international custom
does not allow these crimes
to be qualified as crimes against humanity.
Since they cannot be
qualified in national law,
as we have just seen,
international law
does not apply either,
this is what the Court tells us.
Besides, since there is
no qualification
of crimes against humanity,
the facts are prescribed
by the law of 1962,
sorry, not 1964, 1962.
What is at stake here
is the very definition
of the crime against humanity,
meaning that until 1994,
French law did not recognize
the crime against humanity
with the exception of crimes committed
during the Second World War
by the Axis,
namely the Germans
and Italians.
The Court of Cassation refuses
to qualify Algerian crimes
as crimes against humanity
and therefore, applies
the amnesty law of 1962
to it and does not apply
imprescriptibility to it,
does not apply
the qualification of crimes
against humanity to it.
This is something strange,
why?
Well, strange...
it can be explained politically.
Legally, it could have had
a completely different result.
That is to say, first, it could have said
that the definition that was
in Nuremberg, the one that
I spoke to you about
earlier in the introduction,
applied
to the crimes committed
in Algeria.
Why did it applied?
Because the Nuremberg statute
imposed a jurisdiction
for the tribunal
which stopped at war,
but did not impose a definition
of crimes against humanity
that stopped at crimes
committed by the Germans.
That is the first thing.
Here, it could have come
to another conclusion.
Secondly, the Court
of Cassation tells us
that since the crimes were defined in 1994,
they cannot be applied before then.
However, in the Barbie judgment
of which I spoke to you earlier,
it is quite clear that the Court
applies crimes against humanity
before 1994, since the decision,
first, dates from before 1994;
second, it applies to acts
committed in 1944,
and that it could
have done it retroactively
It could have done so,
in particular by basing itself,
and this leads to the third argument,
on international custom,
namely to say: OK, French
law may not have applied,
but by virtue
of international custom,
there was indeed, after 1945,
the existence of crimes against humanity
or war crimes
that correspond to acts
committed by the French army
in Algeria.
Thus, here is a very clear
and very strict interpretation
of the principle of legality,
an interpretation
which is correct
to a certain extent,
but which could have led
to something else,
even if, in my opinion, on this point,
the Court of Cassation is quite right,
and in particular in view
of the latest case law
of the European Court
of Human Rights
with which France
must comply.
Moreover, on the question
of the amnesty
which the Court takes
for granted with the 1962 law,
it is clear that if in 62,
this amnesty could apply
to these crimes, today,
we know very well,
in particular under international law
and international criminal law,
that amnesty
is not acceptable
or at least for international crimes.
So we have seen
very clearly appear
for some twenty years now
in the jurisprudence
of the European Court
of Human Rights,
in the jurisprudence
of the Inter-American Court
of Human Rights
and in the jurisprudence
of the international criminal courts,
the rejection of the amnesty.
Therefore, the French
high court
could have accepted
that this amnesty was not valid.
This raises a question
of the retroactivity of the non-amnesty.
This is where I refer you
to the previous argument,
to say that this argument could also
have been evacuated
rather quickly.
There you have it for the crimes
committed in Algeria
and the way they were treated
by the French courts.
Let's move on, if you will,
to our second point,
namely the nuclear tests.
As far as the nuclear tests
are concerned,
you should know
that they began in 1960,
that as early as 1959, there was
a resolution of the United Nations
General Assembly, resolution 42/80,
which asked France
not to carry out these nuclear tests.
France expressly refused
to comply with this resolution,
claiming that the British,
American and Russian arsenal
was such that it was necessary
to protect itself.
To protect itself, it was necessary
to conduct nuclear tests
to create this nuclear bomb.
In addition, France maintained
at the time an argument
that the radioactive fallout
would not be significant.
We saw the result, cancers,
diseases, deaths afterward.
We need to remember
that at the time
there were no treaties
prohibiting those nuclear tests.
There were also no customs
Certainly, some doctrines
consider that those nuclear tests
are a violation of the convention
that represses genocide,
the 1948 Convention,
or of the International Covenant
on Civil and Political Rights
that was being drafted at the time.
It seems rather
unrealistic to me.
One question that has not been asked is:
can we consider
that those nuclear tests
are crimes against humanity?
We will have to think
about this.
It was not asked like that.
However, I think that
one could support it,
or at least try to support it.
Note, however, that if there was
no criminal procedure
in the strict sense of the term,
there was recognition
of those nuclear tests
and the repercussions
on the victims.
This recognition took place
and its repercussions,
this recognition of the repercussions
took place through a law,
the Morin Law of 2010,
and this law allows
the victims of French
nuclear tests,
whether in Algeria
or in French Polynesia,
to ask for reparation.
This law allows them to ask for reparation
with something quite interesting.
First, it reverses
the proof of causality.
The law clearly states
that if people prove
that they are ill
and that they were present
in the surroundings of the nuclear tests
carried out by France,
already in the Sahara,
then the victims can have
access to reparations.
It is not a criminal conviction,
they are reparations,
it is mainly
financial reparations,
but the law says it within a very strict
framework, namely that there must be
particular diseases.
These diseases are
as follows.
They are listed in a decree,
decree 2014-1049
which follows on
from the Morin law of 2010.
These are leukemia,
but not chronic
lymphoid leukemia,
since the doctors considered
that it was not radio induced,
meaning that it did not
come from radioactivity,
myelodysplasias,
breast cancers,
thyroid cancers for an exposure
during the period of growth,
as a child, skin cancers,
but not malignant melanomas,
lung cancers,
colon cancers,
salivary gland cancers,
etc.
I refer you to the text
of the decree 2014-1049.
That is, for these diseases,
there is a reversal of causality.
If there are no such diseases,
if there are other diseases
and a priori, there are other diseases
that were induced
by exposure
to radiation,
then there is no
presumption of causality,
which does not mean that
there can be no compensation.
This means that it is necessary to prove
the link, which is complicated
because the law was there
precisely to frame this causality.
What is even more complicated
is that if French military veterans
were able to be compensated
because they had paper
showing that they were
indeed present on the spot,
because there are
army records,
the local civilian populations have
difficulty proving this.
Since they have a hard time proving that,
well there is no compensation.
There is only one known case
of a local civilian woman
who was compensated
for the death of her husband
a few decades later,
but that's the only case.
It is the only case
and it is quite unique.
We could talk about it again
if you want a little later.
So, reparations if we can prove
that we were present,
in the case of particular diseases,
but nothing more.
That is all
for the nuclear tests.
Some avenues for reflection that
we will discuss again during the class
and the questions and answers
at the beginning of October.
First, a question
of qualification.
Today we must try,
not to qualify the crimes.
Thus, the first part
that we talked about, the events,
because these are crimes
against humanity, without doubt,
even if the Court of Cassation
has ruled that out,
but the question must be asked
whether nuclear tests
are or can be qualified
as crimes against humanity.
For that,
we must take up
the statute of
the International Criminal Court,
which gives the law
in force today,
to see if we can qualify this
as a crime against humanity.
Note that even if we were able to do this,
it does not mean,
given the arguments
of the Court of Cassation,
that we could assert this
before the French courts.
But in any case,
it would already be a point,
of crimes against humanity,
perhaps of war crimes.
Why?
Because since Nuremberg,
war crimes
against the environment
have been elaborated,
have been incriminated.
One might wonder if
the nuclear tests in the Sahara
are not crimes against
the environment
or if there is something to be done here,
there is a little bit of digging to be done.
Moreover, we must work again,
we must research,
we must do research
on this question
of imprescriptibility.
Why?
Because this imprescriptibility
is questionable,
is questionable because
if we manage
to qualify the different crimes
as crimes against humanity,
a priori, we should be able to say
that these crimes are imprescriptible,
which would mean that
if at the time of their acts,
they were already provided for
by an international law,
which was the case,
they should not be able
to be prescribed.
Penally speaking, we have seen
that this does not lead to much.
On the other hand,
one could wonder whether
international or national authorities,
and I will come to this,
it would be worthwhile
to rework this question
of imprescriptibility.
Finally,
and this is the most
important thing,
we must think about
several procedures.
First of all, as far as
procedures are concerned,
procedures in France,
apart from the question
of reparations,
but even then it is necessary to find
proof in relation to the nuclear tests,
there is little chance
of success.
Therefore, the procedures in France
should focus mainly
on, first, the nuclear tests,
qualifying them
as crimes against humanity.
That, I think, has not
been researched enough
Second,
see civil reparation
procedures
by the Algerian victims,
by providing proof
that they were indeed present.
Still at the national level,
another possible procedure,
and this is research
that must be done,
that you must do,
is to see if it is not possible
to lodge a complaint,
to bring before the Algerian civil judge,
the events,
the cases, the crimes,
the nuclear tests,
thus, to bring a complaint
against the French State,
but before
the Algerian courts,
against French nationals,
but before the Algerian courts.
I do not know Algerian Law.
I do not know Algerian procedures.
Since the French
can judge by universal jurisdiction
or by other links of connection,
foreigners on its territory,
why Algeria could not?
Here we are going to take
into account other problems,
political problems,
diplomatic problems,
but legally, it might be worth it.
Then, at the international level, it is clear
that the international criminal tribunals,
the International Criminal Court
are not bodies
which have jurisdiction.
So I have not mentioned them
and I exclude them.
On the other hand,
one could wonder
if something could not be done
before the European Court of Human Rights
for nuclear tests
as for international crimes.
For that we must review a little
what is the jurisprudence of the Court
and then perhaps
in a much less
aggressive way,
but maybe more diplomatic,
to try to go also
before the Human Rights Committee.
For these jurisdictions,
for these instances,
it could be interesting
to carry out procedures
and I come back to my previous point,
in Algeria to say
that they are not effective,
because they will
certainly not be successful,
and to go before
the United Nations committees.
I suggest you keep
this in mind.
We will talk about this again
in a few days or weeks,
depending on when
you see me on video.
Thank you for your attention
and I'll see you soon.